ça fait maintenant plusieurs jours que
le thermomètre dépasse allègrement les
30 degrés sur la ville de tours ayant
elle-même même atteint les 40 degrés
mais alors quels sont les endroits les
plus chauds de la ville nous sommes avec
frédéric miniou frédéric mignot adjoint
au maire de tours mais avant tout gérant
du bureau d'études énergie eau un îlot
de chaleur qu'est ce que c'est alors un
îlot de chaleur urbains c'est une
concentration extrême des températures
une augmentation extrême des
températures par rapport à ce qu'on peut
appeler un îlot trasher urbain c'est un
endroit qui peut végétalisée qui a des
matériaux qui sont qui est attiré garde
la chaleur et qui font que on va
constater une température bien
supérieure à la température qui est
mesurée par météo france et bien partons
à la chasse aux îlots de chaleur dans la
ville
[Musique]
nous sommes ici sur le parvis du palais
des congrès de tours l'un des endroits
les plus chauds de la ville à la
retraite avec miniou quels sont les
facteurs d'un îlot de chaleur comme
celui ci alors donc déjà vous pouvez le
constater c'est complètement dégagé on
n'a pas de végétation la végétation
s'arrête à une cinquantaine de mètres
donc on n'a pas l'effet bénéfique de la
végétation ensuite c'est le sol et
compléments minéralisée dont quelques
uns des matériaux qui absorbent la
chaleur et retient la chaleur si par
exemple le matériau était blanc bas ils
auraient tendance à rejeter la chaleur
au lieu de l'absorber même température
ici qui va être certainement de 4,5
degrés supérieures la température qui
est mesurée par météo france est
annoncée par météo-france assez fort si
on a pas que des mauvaises nouvelles non
plus à vous annoncer est ce qu'on va
faire quelques pas pour aller trouver un
îlot de fraîcheur
[Musique]
nous sommes seulement à 150 mètres du
parvis du palais des congrès dans les
jardins de la préfecture est ici pour le
coup c'est un îlot de fraîcheur ce qu'on
appelle un îlot de fraîcheur urbain donc
en fait le différentiel de température
entre le parvis du vinci et le jardin de
la préfecture ces 7 degrés donc
forcément on est bien plus à l'aise ici
et avec des alliés incommensurable qui
sont les arbres puisque les arbres sont
l'équivalent de 5 climatiseurs à eux
tous seuls le sol qui permet la
pénétration de l'eau de pluie quand il
ya de l'eau pluie et donc qu'ils
restituent une forme de fraîcheur est
donc l'objectif dans nos villes qui sont
hélas trop minérale cédait déminéralisée
les villes de façon à créer des îlots de
fraîcheur urbain
en effet il ya des problèmes de chaleur
un partout dans les villes et en
particulier ici à tour mais il ya
également des solutions pour éviter que
ces chaleurs au dessus de 40 degrés ne
subsiste c'est un petit peu la crainte
des climatologues